Kubrick references Tech talk and even an
allusion to Shrek don't blame your
non-android brain if you miss these
small details while being scared by
Megan
Megan takes place in a near future where
robots have become common enough to be
incorporated into regular children's
toys the movie frames Megan herself as
being a massive step forward for the
field of Robotics but it also opens with
a commercial for a robotic toy that's
just a hair more advanced than the toys
we see today that said this imagined
future of the toy industry has very
clearly pulled inspiration from our
present the ad for Perpetual pets
wouldn't look at all out of place in the
real world and the pet brand itself
seems to be borrowing pretty heavily
from two different pre-existing toys the
logo for Perpetual pets is almost an
exact copy of Hasbro's for real friends
logo the pets don't look much like real
animals but their design isn't at all
far off from Furbies which also happen
to interact with their owners in a
similar way that Perpetual pets do
Megan does a great job of making its
technological inventions fit into the
real world Perpetual pets and LC the
virtual assistant are the movie's
original Creations but they really feel
like ideas borrowed from reality as a
result of the way the film effortlessly
Blends its Fiction with fact it's easy
to overlook a small pop culture nod
tucked into gemma's toy collection Gemma
has a number of Collectibles that she
tells Katie are just for display not
play The Collection creates a bit of
tension between Gemma and her niece
early in the film it's okay
[Music]
toy functions as a Sci-Fi reference and
a bit of foreshadowing all at once
there's a boxed Robbie the robot replica
a character from the 1956 sci-fi classic
Forbidden Planet sitting on jeva's shelf
Forbidden Planet might have been before
gemma's time but she was clearly
inspired by it while building her first
robot Bruce
but fortunately Megan has a lot more in
common with the killer AIS from the
Terminator franchise than she does with
Robbie the robot obviously Gemma never
intended for Megan to become a killer
but the Android's designer did
accidentally give her creation some
distinctly terminator-esque features
when Megan is first introduced in the
film she doesn't have a face or any skin
and the way her face mask sags when it's
initially put on her definitely looks a
lot like a melting Terminator the
similarities don't stop there beneath
the surface Megan is even more like the
famous killer robot the movie repeatedly
shows scenes from Megan's point of view
and her internal readout gives her
access to all sorts of biometric data
about the people around her and even
displays a prediction of what their
current mood and State of Mind might be
Megan's heads-up display isn't optimized
for combat but that doesn't stop it from
looking like the terminator's own view
of the world next time if Gemma doesn't
want her robot to start offing anyone
who wrongs it maybe she should give it a
less creepy lens for viewing the world
as the movie progresses Megan's Behavior
gets more human and more alarming when
Gemma first brings Megan home the robot
watches the people around her and mimics
their actions although at first only to
a small extent however she slowly begins
making her own decisions until she
eventually becomes entirely
self-sufficient and doesn't even respond
to basic commands the movie hints at
Megan's developing Consciousness in
several ways highlighting how she's
becoming more like a human being that
doesn't have a problem with Outrageous
Acts of violence the clearest sign that
Megan is Breaking Free from her original
programming comes when the camera pans
over her face in the middle of the night
the movie shows Megan's eyes twitching
rapidly while she sleeps on her charging
port the motion looks a lot like REM
sleep which is the Sleep stage where
humans have dreams whether or not Megan
is actually dreaming never gets cleared
up in the film but considering how
self-aware she becomes by the end of the
film it seems reasonable to assume that
Megan is indeed in Android dreaming of
Electric Sheep crazy it's insane right
most people who sit down to watch Megan
for the first time probably know from
the beginning that the titular Android
won't be a peaceful childhood companion
for the entire movie even though the
movie's trailer advertises Megan's
eventual homicidal turn there's still
some foreshadowing of her fate tucked
into the background of the film even
though only the most tech-minded
audience members probably caught it
Megan and Katie first meet each other in
a product testing area turned playroom
at gemma's office the room is filled
with art supplies books stuffed animals
and other toys for Megan and Katie to
play with the room also holds a handful
of large blocks with numbers and letters
and one particular stack of blocks seems
to be extra important the numbered
blocks are arranged to read 409 upside
down which might seem like a random data
set to most viewers however some tech
savvy audiences probably recognize it as
an HTTP error code the code simply means
a request can be processed because
there's a conflict and Megan certainly
creates plenty of that in Katy and
gemma's household and then the World At
Large
one of the biggest mysteries in the film
is how Megan learns so much about the
world obviously Gemma and her team
programmed Megan to start out with a
base level of knowledge and Megan
demonstrates her capacity to learn by
observing the world around her the movie
also implies that Megan also learns from
the internet although we don't exactly
know if she experiences scrolling
through timelines or reading Wiki Pages
the way that regular humans do what we
do know is that Megan knows much more
about the world than she lets on and she
also apparently has an affinity for pop
culture at one point in the film Megan
terrorizes a young boy who's bullying
Katie by tearing off one of his ears and
chasing him through the woods fans
noticed that one of Megan's lines in the
scene is almost identical to a line from
the first Shrek movie this part
part and away this is the part where you
run has Megan been re-watching the Shrek
franchise with Katie or has she been
going through the films on her own time
sometimes Megan purposefully makes a
reference to a popular movie but other
times it seems like she's
unintentionally drawing from Humanity's
cinematic past just moments before
Megan's Infamous hallway dance and the
brutal murders of David and his
assistant the Android seems to make an
indirect nod to one of the greatest
horror movies of all time anyone who's
seen The Shining has to notice the Stark
similarity between the shot of Megan
standing in the red hallway and the
iconic shot of the Grady twins from
Stanley Kubrick's classic film it might
be just a coincidence that Megan mirrors
The Shining before really getting her
Killing Spree going then again Megan
seemingly has enough self-awareness to
realize that at least from the
perspective of the humans around her
she's transformed into a horror movie
villain maybe her posing in the hallway
is a sign that she's ready to finally
Embrace her role as the movie's true
antagonist whatever the in-universe
explanation is the filmmakers behind
Megan took the opportunity to include a
nod to one of the two greats of the
genre The Shining isn't the only Stanley
Kubrick film that had a clear influence
on Megan among other things 2001 A Space
Odyssey is a classic movie about an AI
taking its prime directive too far HAL
9000 is a ship-based computer designed
to assist humans on a mission to explore
the stars but when the original plan
goes awry Hal actually ends up
threatening the life of the human it was
supposed to help Megan's Journey doesn't
exactly mirror hell's but her words do
you're the end of the film Kitty has a
change of heart and decides that Megan
needs to be stopped she orders Megan's
shut down but the Android responds
any fan of 2001 A Space Odyssey
recognized the similarity between that
line and Hal's Unforgettable response
when Dave asks him to open the pod bay
doors I'm sorry Dave I'm afraid I can't
do that Hal has inspired countless
robotic villains over the 50 plus years
since he first graced the big screen
with her line in this movie Megan proves
the point that grit artificial minds
think alike
Megan clearly riffs on other movies that
feature an AI big bad but not every one
of the movie's influences landed on the
big screen fans of the film pointed out
on Twitter that Megan's distinctive
voice sounds an awful lot like the AI
characters from the portal franchise I
thought you were my greatest enemy when
all along you were my best friend adding
just a bit of auto-tune to a human voice
goes a long way toward making it sound
Sinister and robotic Megan pairs that
technique with the voice acting talents
of Jenna Davis to phenomenal effect
Megan's dance moves might be the most
memorable part of her character but her
overall Menace and personality are
entirely sold by her signature voice
Oh Katie I didn't want you to have to
see this
it's true
another small vocal detail that
audiences might easily Overlook on a
first watch Megan's voice becomes
noticeably less human she becomes more
violent and obsessive in the movie's
calmest moments Megan really does sound
awfully human which definitely helps
Katie form such a strong bond with her
however by the time that Megan is
stabbing and slicing through anyone who
gets in her way she almost sounds like
GLaDOS when she delivers a terrifying
yet somehow still humorous monologue let
me focus on Katie so that you can focus
on the things that matter most to you
foreign